- Hannah Gutierrez Reed finally speaks out
through her lawyers about her
involvement or lack thereof
in the death of Halyna
Hutchins on the set of Rust.
She claims that it was sabotage.
Now this allegation or speculation
probably doesn't change
anything on the video I did
regarding the whole shooting situation,
but there are a couple
of interesting wrinkles.
Number one,
if someone did intentionally
put a live round into the gun,
that would almost certainly
qualify as what's called
depraved heart murder.
Effectively, that person
would have engaged
in an act that was wildly reckless,
and very likely to end up
hurting or killing someone
and that is often grounds for
murder in the second degree.
Number two, this probably
doesn't help Ms. Gutierrez Reed
if it's her job to check the gun
and check every round
before it's used in a scene,
the fact that someone
intentionally put it there,
doesn't obviate the need
to actually go through
and check every single round.
Maybe it would help if
someone added the round
after she had checked the gun,
but then that raises
questions of chain of custody.
Why was the gun in such a place
that it allowed someone else
to put that round in
outside of her supervision?
So this is interesting speculation,
but probably not the legal
defense that she thinks it is.